[Music]
Cyprus is an end end testing library
that will change your life as a
developer I say that because it allows
you to speed up the testing process of
the user experience and it will help you
catch bugs that you didn't even know
existed it's super easy to set up and
the learning curve is very minimal so if
you have an existing app I recommend
that you follow along with this episode
in your own project to see what I mean
first hand if you're new to the channel
make sure to LIKE and subscribe and you
can find the source code at angular
firebase com in case you're not familiar
and testing is the process of loading up
your web application in the browser and
testing things as if it was a real user
performing these actions such as
clicking buttons filling out forms and
things like that
so if you're an angular developer you
might already know that angular ships
with its own and and testing library
called protractor so why do we need
Cypress the short answer is that Cypress
just provides a better developer
experience but the longer answer is that
protractor was originally developed for
angularjs and it just hasn't evolved the
way Cypress has first of all Cypress
provides a really nice DSL for writing
expressive and and tests which we'll see
in the code here coming up then it
provides this really nice test Runner
which is an electron app that will run
your app in the browser
and then give you time travel debugging
capabilities for each spec so for every
action that takes place in the app it
will save a snapshot of the state as
well as an image of the UI so you know
how things change before and after some
action took place and in my experience
writing a really good test suite is much
more effective at preventing bugs than
using a state management library like
redux or something along those lines for
this project I'm going to be starting
from the firestarter demo app which
already has user authentication and a
buyer store database feature implemented
in it over the next few minutes we'll
test that the user can sign up log out
log back in create some items in the
database and do a few other things in
between the first thing we need to do is
install it with NPM install Cypress save
dev then I'm also installing a library
called chance which we'll use to
generate random fixtures for our specs I
have completely removed protractor from
this project and I'm going into the
package.json and changing the end-to-end
script to say Cypress open now you can
run the script from the command line and
it will take you through a series of
steps to set up Cypress and your project
I also highly recommend that you link
your github project to it because you
can actually record your test and then
save them in the cloud recordings are
great for your own reference but they're
even better if you have clients that
want to see the user experience happen
step by step when you finish the setup
you'll see a few new things in your
project Cypress JSON holds your global
configuration options then all of your
testing code is in the Cypress directory
you can set up your specs to run on
typescript but I don't see much benefit
in doing that because you can pull in
the types in just a plain JavaScript
file as well you'll notice four
different files here fixtures hold
default data that you want to reuse
throughout your tests then integration
is where you write your main specs
that's where we'll spend most of the
time here you can also write plug-ins
that hook into different life cycle
events in the testing process one
example would be transpiling your code
to typescript if you decide to use TS
and then you have a support directory
where you can write your own custom
commands for Cypress or overwrite
existing commands we'll do this later in
the video at this point I just want to
jump into writing our first test because
it's really easy to do I have created a
file called sample spec j/s in the
integration folder then I'll reference
the types so we can get really good
tooling and autocomplete in our plain
JavaScript file and I'll also bring in
chance so we can automatically generate
email addresses and text and things like
that at this point it's important to
point out that Cypress uses mocha and
chai as its underlying test libraries so
you can't really use just or Jasmine as
far as I know but this doesn't really
matter because you'll mostly be using
the Cypress API to write your specs the
first step is to describe the test suite
which we'll call fire starter and then
I'll set a couple global variables here
one is for an email address that will be
randomly generated for each time this
test runs and then another one for the
password the state does not get reset
between each test so if you want to go
back to the home page for example you
can set up a before each callback to
redirect the user back to the home page
which we can do with side visit and the
URL before we get started testing
anything complex let's just make sure we
can find some text within the rendered
page
kollene cy contains we'll look for that
text in the page and that's all you need
to write to test that that content is in
the page but you can also write more
traditional test code where you explicit
we declare your subject for example if
we expect two to equal two I have very
rarely write tests like this in Cyprus
but I just want you to know that it's
possible so if we look at the spec you
can see it first ran R before each
callback then it lets us know whether
our tests passed or failed and if we
hover over that contains it will
highlight where it found that text in
the page in this particular app I have
router guard setup to block certain
routes if an unauthenticated user tries
to access them in this next spec i'll
show you how to navigate around the app
and then verify that that particular
route gets blocked this app has a
drop-down on mobile layouts so we need
to make sure the actual link that we
want to click is visible on the page
before we try to click it with cyprus
which in this case means clicking the
element that has an ID of nav toggle to
do that we can call Cyprus get along
with a selector which works very similar
to jQuery the get method is very
powerful and you'll be using it
frequently in Cyprus so once we click
that button the page then should contain
the words firestorm and then we'll go
ahead and click on that link which
should normally bring us to the
firestore page however it's currently
blocked by a router guard so it should
show a notification message that that
user is not authorized to visit that
page in this app I have a notification
message component which I can grab and
then I'll get the children elements from
that component and somewhere inside
those Dom elements we should have the
text you must be logged in this should
method is super powerful in Cyprus you
can chain it on to any element that
you've grabbed to make assertions about
it for the first argument you can chain
assertions together then the second
argument is optional and is the value
that you want to compare what's really
nice is that we can chain multiple
assertions together by using and for
example this text might be contained in
the Dom but we also want to make sure
that it's visible to the user which we
can do by asserting that the
notification message should be visible
if you uncomment the CY dot paws line of
code that I have at the top of the spec
it'll allow us to go through each item
step by step so with that one line of
code we can just click the next button
up here at the top and it will take us
through each step and show us where the
UI is being clicked and what is
happening in response when it clicks the
button it will navigate to a new URL and
then you'll see at asserts that that
notification message has the
corresponding text so now let's go ahead
and sign up a new user and we'll do this
with email
passwords so we actually have to type
into a form the first thing we'll do is
click the toggle button and then click
the log in link then we'll make sure
that that takes the user back to the URL
page which we can do with Cypress URL
and then a should assertion now a best
practice I'd like to point out is that
you should generally avoid using IDs or
CSS classes to select elements from the
Dom that'll make your test brittle
because those things are likely to
change a better approach is to use a
data attribute or the actual component
name itself in this case I'm using the
name attribute on an input element which
is very unlikely to change in most cases
then if you remember earlier we set up a
global email address so I can simply
type that email address into the form
with the type operator I'll do the same
thing for the password then find the
submit button and click it then we can
verify that we have this new user and we
could even verify things and local
storage but for now we'll just make sure
that it has the right message in the
page and then from there we'll go ahead
and log the user out so we can log them
back in in the next step when we time
travel through the spec you can see that
it's actually typing in the randomly
generated email address into the form
input and then it highlights the submit
button with the red dot shows you that
it gets clicked and then it navigates
back to the new page with the proper
message displayed then you'll also see
all of the a synchronous xhr requests
that firebase is making with the
identity toolkit to login the user the
next thing I want to do is show you how
to extend Cyprus with your own custom
method so let's imagine we often need to
login the user to do something in our
app instead of repeating our test code
over and over again I'm going to create
a login method that we can reuse
throughout our test Suites we will go
into the support folder and then in
commands and then call Cyprus commands
add the second argument is just a
function that will run the steps needed
to execute this command in most cases
you'd probably want to log the user in
programmatically but in this case we'll
just go ahead and have the user click
different UI elements until they're
logged into their account so what we've
really done is just created a helper
method that we can use in our specs to
keep them concise and readable so
getting back to our main spec now we can
log the user in that we just logged out
in the previous spec and then do
whatever else we need to do with the
logged in user
the bottom line is it's just a really
convenient way to share code throughout
your tests there's so much more you can
do with Cypress that I'll have to make a
whole nother video about more advanced
concepts again the API is really well
documented and intuitive so I recommend
that you give it a try
I've been using it for the last few
weeks and it's completely changed the
way that I do and and testing and
angular I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you're
ready to start building a serious app
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase com you'll get access
to all kinds of exclusive content
designed to get your app into production
faster thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you soon